le chantier aura duré huit ans les
quinze mille mètres carrés du lycée
jules hardouin mansart à saint cyr
l'école ont été entièrement modernisé
montant des travaux un peu plus de 50
millions d'euros un budget entièrement
supporté par la région ile de france
on n'a pas voulu faire petit bout par
petit bout mais dans une cohérence pour
avoir un lycée du 21e siècle avec vous
le savez des moyens de technologie bien
sûr différent et une manières
d'enseigner d'appréhender les lieux qui
évidemment ne pouvait pas se contenter
d'un investissement qui n'auraient pas
été justement tourné vers l'avenir un
lycée du futur avec des façades ont pas
un rétifié un matériau destiné à durer
dans le temps
le bâtiment aux normes haute qualité
environnementale laisse également
beaucoup de place à la lumière
c'est un élément moteur de la conception
de ce projet c'est la lumière la
luminosité partout la fluidité la
souplesse en opposition avec la barre
qui était quand même très obsolètes
était très fatigué
je dis toujours c'est un bâtiment qui
était grippé cdi salle de classe ou
encore préau tout a été refait pour le
bien-être et la réussite des 8 118
élèves
malgré tout la communauté scolaire a dû
cohabiter pendant huit ans avec les
travaux ça a été parfois des joies
immenses et des souffrances importantes
et une communauté scolaire à ressouder
ce qui me rend heureux c'est que la
plupart des professeurs qui ont débuté
dans le construction sont toujours là
aujourd'hui
désormais les élèves du lycée jules
hardouin mansart ont toutes les cartes
en main pour étudier dans des conditions
idéales